please to New York are investigating a
violent confrontation between officers
and a mother holding her young baby cell
phone video shows 23 year old Jasmine
Headley surrounded by New York police
officers and a security guard at a
social services office the officers can
be seen aggressively pulling the
one-year-old child from her arms Rica
Duncan a7 New York Police Headquarters
with how this confrontation began and
the foldout Jericka this is so
disturbing you see this video good
morning to you good morning Jasmine
Headley was at the Social Services
office because of concern for a child
care benefit that allowed her to
maintain her job well now police are
trying to figure out how and why the
situation escalated Jasmine Headley
screams filled the Brooklyn Social
Services office during a chaotic
tug-of-war with police over her
one-year-old son
Damone witnesses say it started as a
confrontation with the security guard
about sitting on the floor with no other
seats available I was just so disgusted
and I couldn't believe they was doing
that to that child like I just couldn't
believe it it was crazy an officer could
be seen pulling her stun gun on the
crowd at one point Headley was arrested
and faces charges that include resisting
arrest and criminal trespass the child
was turned over to Headley's mother who
says Headley was trying to protect her
son there was no reason for white PD to
tug and pull like the way they did with
him he was a ragdoll
basically police say Headley refused to
leave the office or comply with officers
orders when they arrived New York Police
Commissioner James O'Neill called the
video very disturbing
adding the incident is under
investigation the city's social services
commissioner says they will immediately
focus on training to better defuse
situations before the NYPD is called we
call them for those charges to be
immediately dropped Eric Adams is the
Brooklyn borough president and former
New York City police officer
you cannot escalate to that level that
was not an emergency
it was not a violent crime it was about
a conversation it was about let's find
this woman in a chair Headley is
currently being held at Rikers prison on
an unrelated charge she's expected to
appear in court on Thursday as for those
two Human Resources officers that were
also involved in this incident they have
been placed on leave the New York City
Police Department is not able to release
body cam video at this time because of
an injunction just very very disturbing
Jericka thank you